welcome to this video is mr. cool visit
that's Dmitri yo winko 0 out of 3 with
that account yeah i know i have beaten
him once but it's once or twice with
over the all accounts um yeah Yoko vengo
is a 27 something guy chaton 720 30
around this ballpark I'm playing my
repertoire here from my book let's see
what he is coming up with probably d
takes d5 that is what they all do d
takes d5 here or one move later yeah
it's best to exchange one pair of nights
here at least that's my opinion that
what i came up with when I'm preparing
the book 83 there should be seven or
Bishop c5 I think we should be seven I'm
not totally sure I think this is right
c6 and we should be six here Bishop f5
as a move I want a set here Bishop f5
Queen takes Queen d2
okay this is kind of I'm hoping that
this is the moment there is one moment
where this move is right and let's let's
hope this is the one I think it is but
not entirely sure yeah ship well Bishop
t6 and then I can take P tool or is
there a better move no i don't think so
i can go to be five so did I screw it up
maybe I did I can also just take between
now no then we'll be warm
um so what's that the wrong moment maybe
it was going be tuned and then you will
take everything should be six queen bee
five I don't really have a decent move
then
if I take be to log a be 156 is that
possible probably is possible
I go to be true may be one as possible
so Queen too I cannot spend a huge time
here now for rugby to maybe see porn is
quick though really is quick
and maybe this on c5 no I don't have 94
stupid
hmm
don't really have any meaningful counter
plank and even go just clean f3m me not
that it's necessary but it is probably
enough
yeah they said it's probably enough
it's really not much that I can do that
seep on the super strong
check
I have to go to see item and it's got
Queen f5 though
queena five will win Luke c7 has made
even time morning queen bee seven when I
mean it's all very easy that's the big
problem not even cannot really hope for
any miracle so easy to do
mmm yeah t8 is just simple and good so
any trick that I can go for no not
really laughs resigns yeah that
everybody was in trouble here already
though I wasn't really sure that is the
precise moment where Bishop f5 is
equalizing I would really need to look
that up there is one moment where it is
and one moment wait isn't this might be
the wrong moment I couldn't remember
precisely mean queen c6 is just normal
in this position and probably good yeah
probably just see six in this ago i'm
not sure where is it possibly is it
better there is one instance where this
is better maybe without a three and down
without a 3 NB should be seven like here
it's he I am it's this position yeah
this is what I confused i wasn't sure i
will show here here this is the right
move and he had isn't and i wasn't i
wasn't sure even during the game now now
I'm really in trouble he has screen b5
covering this and yeah I'm just worse
did sir probably a Sandman he has got
some choice so I have to in this precise
move order avoid Bishop f5 and 26 after
which honestly I don't think that
whitens much to write home about he's
got a slight advantage at best this is a
bit weakish the screen side but it's not
huge something like this this queen here
97 sometimes I can go at five it seems
seems okay yeah I wasn't sure about the
move water the end it was the wrong the
wrong moment okay well thanks for
watching